[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight it is now clear that for many of
our elected leaders it's not even worth
having a country if that country comes
with real borders the federal government
you may have heard is on the brink of
shutting down tomorrow if Congress can't
come to an agreement on funding it the
main stumbling block remains daca that's
of course President Obama's program that
gives work permits to illegal immigrants
who came here as minors almost all
Democrats and many Republicans are
pushing for an amnesty for daca
recipients as well as from millions of
other illegal immigrants there's a
striking fanaticism to their position
illegal immigrants must be kept in this
country at all cost no matter what for
Democrats is understandable because the
calculus is simple having abandoned the
concerns of the middle class here they
need millions of new voters and they
need them fast
otherwise their party risks becoming a
permanent minority replacing ungrateful
citizens with obedient immigrants is
their only hope every Democrat has
thought it through for even a minute
knows this well they can't say it in
public though because obviously it's
horrible so instead they're trying a new
talking point illegal immigrants are
terrific people every single one of them
far more noble and law-abiding than you
are how dare you complain about their
presence you must be a bigot the one
problem with this line of argument is
that it's vulnerable to facts but until
recently there really were few reliable
numbers on crimes committed by illegal
immigrants and this allowed Democrats to
pretend that every person who stinks
across our border goes on to become a
heart surgeon or a member of SEAL Team
six we've got the data now and it turns
out surprise surprise they've been lying
to you in the border state of Arizona
for example illegal immigrants commit
two and a half times as many murders as
American citizens do they're almost 50%
more likely to be in gangs they commit
more than armed robbery and more sex
crimes against children overall they're
about twice as likely to be convicted of
crimes of all kinds non immigration
related and that's just in one state in
California in illegal alien named Luis
Barroso Montes murdered two police
officers Brasa Montez had been deported
from this country multiple times in each
case he came back thanks to politicians
who have zero in
and keeping people like him out in court
this Tuesday bra Samanta is bragged
about his plans to escape from prison
and murder more so illegal immigration
divides the country it lowers wages for
those who can least afford it and in
some cases it literally costs Americans
their lives so why are we doing this
because it's our moral duty that's what
our leaders are telling us we have to
that's who we are just days ago the
Senate's most celebrated moral
philosopher Lindsey Graham of South
Carolina spoke for the country's entire
ruling class when he explained the
rationale for his views on immigration
diversity is our strength now you've
heard that phrase before obviously you
hear it every day
in effect it's our new national motto
seems to replace the outdated and in
fact polar opposite sentiment EEP
pluribus unum diversity is our strength
it'll be in our currency before long
trust me but what exactly does it mean
you may have noticed that nobody ever
bothers to explain exactly what it means
and more pressingly is it true the less
we have in common the stronger we are is
a marriage stronger when spouses have
radically different beliefs are you
closer to your kids when you share no
common points of reference
do you speak the same language as your
best friend could you be best friends if
you didn't these are important questions
given that our leaders are radically and
permanently changing our country wholly
on the basis of their faith that
diversity is in fact our strength maybe
we should have talked this through ahead
of time somehow we didn't House Majority
Leader Kevin McCarthy tried to start
that conversation today and here's part
of what he said we did not survive grow
and become the most powerful
civilization in human history because we
are focused on our diversity it is not
our differences that makes us stronger
it is our unity despite our diversity
unity and past of principles and of the
purpose that brought us out of many and
to one
in other words diversity isn't our
strength unity is our strength
don't the left why do you that doesn't
mean we have to look alike doesn't mean
we have to come from the same places it
does mean we have to share common
beliefs otherwise we'll hate each other
and the whole enterprise will fall apart
that's true in families it's true in
friendships and it's true in countries
too you already knew that because it's
obvious our leaders spend most of their
time denying it they're lying to us
iego is a phoenix City Councilmember
she's running for mayor in that city and
she supports the continuation of daca
she joins us tonight
okaygo thanks for joining us appreciate
it thank you so much for having me so
trying to think through how legalizing
people who are here illegally helps
American citizens in in Arizona we have
some data on this because it the state
passed as you know one of the toughest
anti-immigration laws in the country in
2010 and the effects that have been
studied and here's what they showed
there was a short-term labor shortage
obviously people here to work they can't
work there was a labor shortage but
overtime automation made up for it and
wages went up for American workers costs
meanwhile went down prison costs went
down education cost went down
dramatically but hundreds of millions of
dollars so given that we know that why
does it help the economy to legalize
people here illegally right now the City
of Phoenix is the fastest growing city
in the entire country we added more
people in 2016 than on any other city
and we're constrained by our workforce
right now we just had some folks from
the homebuilding industry come into the
City of Phoenix and say we could do so
much more if we had a larger
construction workforce we could be
creating jobs we could building built
building new affordable homes for people
to live in but we don't have the
workforce we need and they said that the
point that they really feel like it's
changed was not having enough people
through immigration yeah losing out ya
know a lot of employers make that case
and they mean it they want obviously
cheaper labor I think all employers do
why wouldn't they but if that's true if
more illegal immigrants make a place
richer
then how many specifically do you think
Arizona or Phoenix needs how many
illegals do you need in your city to
make it richer would more be better
about 10 million would that make it even
richer right now we are desperately
concerned about our daca recipients who
are in our city Arizona has 28,000 daca
recipients who have been great members
of our community who went to our high
schools were educated here we've been
investing in them for years now they're
ready to give back and we're worried
about their future right now our
Republican governor has stepped up and
said they're an important part of our
economy we want them to stay right you
know but you just you just said I just
want to get to the nub of it though
because I think it's a big deal I mean
once you legalize people they vote that
bring the relatives it it changes a
place maybe for the better maybe for the
worse but we should be clear about the
effects I think I think you'd agree so
if bringing in more people illegally and
making them citizens makes you more
prosperous then why wouldn't you bring
in 10 million and become really really
rich would that work
immigrants have been amazing
contributors to our community if you
look at some of the data from forward us
Mark Zuckerberg organization so many of
the entrepreneurs who've built our tech
economy came here through immigration
and we in Phoenix are desperate for more
how many and how many how many big tech
companies are were started by people
from Central and South America Latin
America so right now I'm sitting in
Phoenix Arizona very close to a company
called Fortis who was though started by
a gentleman from Panama it's one of our
top engineering companies in this
community and they actually are one of
our largest employers of at-risk
veterans
she's a wonderful success I bet I bet
he's a great guy in the company's great
but how many big tech companies were
started by the immigrants that you're
talking about since you brought it up
how many if you I mean if you look at
we've so many success stories in this
community and some of them have gotten
national attention okay so I just want
to be smooth because it's a big with
respect I mean look I'm not attacking
immigrants I like immigrants and I'm
sure a lot of people are great people
but
people who live here who born here are
citizens have a right to know the
effects of this so how many is the
optimum number if bringing in people
illegally and giving them citizenship
makes you more prosperous what's the
number the ideal number of people we
should give citizenship to our country
in our community was was built by
immigration okay and we have so many
stories in this community I know stories
but I'm looking for facts I think it's
fair to ask for facts so John Lott who's
a researcher or social scientists got a
hold of the conviction numbers which the
government of the state of Arizona has
hidden from the population because it's
lying to the population about the
effects of immigration as you know and
he found that illegal immigrants in the
state of Arizona were more than twice as
likely to commit murder and overall far
more likely to commit crimes of all
kinds not immigration crimes but violent
and property crimes so given that those
are facts how can you reassure the
residents legal residents of Arizona of
all backgrounds that this is good for
them I don't understand we and cities
throughout our community have seen great
success stories when people feel like
they can work with the police department
and there's trust so we've had folks who
did not have legal immigration status
but we're willing to work with our
police department and have been very
important in helping us particularly
with drug related crimes knowledge are
you do you acknowledge the reality of
what I just said so this study which got
a hold of Arizona State numbers which I
think are legitimate says that people
illegally in Arizona are far more likely
to commit serious crime do not believe
that are you just ignoring it or what's
your response to that so I just received
the arrest and crime data from the last
calendar year 2017 for the City of
Phoenix and that wasn't what we found in
the City of Phoenix
unfortunately violent crime was led by
people who live here and who that's not
that's not the question
were people who are there illegally more
likely or less likely to commit serious
crimes in the City of Phoenix are you
really saying they were less likely I
don't think that's what the numbers show
our 2017 numbers tell a very different
story than the story that that
researcher is telling you so were you
saying just to be totally clear we're
almost out of time
are you saying that you've seen numbers
that in the City of Phoenix people here
illegally were less likely to commit
serious crimes than citizens is that
what you're saying I just want to get
you on the record saying we need
comprehensive immigration reform oh oh
you're slipping out of the question I am
asking a very simple question you're not
giving me a real answer and I think that
tells the whole story
thanks for joining us I appreciate it
thanks for having me